oui bonsoir bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle page patrimoine regarder
derrière moi c'est majestueux le logis
latour vérone le musée de la préhistoire
nous sommes bien au grand pressigny un
site remarquable singulier et on va tout
de suite découvrir ce site avec nos deux
invités venez avec moi
[Musique]
bonjour valériane bonjour benoît alors
nous sommes sur un site remarquable je
le disais et nous sommes surtout sur un
éperon rocheux
tout à fait c'est un éperon rocheux qui
a commencé à être construit au 12e
siècle donc avec la réalisation du
donjon qui se situe dans l'autre court
et ce bourgeois était aussi ceinturée de
remparts dont ses remparts sont
construits vraiment au bout de l'éperon
rocheux et qui domine le village du
grand pressigny alors ça a été un zone
géographique où il ya eu beaucoup
d'enjeux dans les confrontations
notamment entre les anglais et les
français au moyen-âge voilà à la fin du
12e siècle les terres appartenant aux
plantages né en france était vraiment
importante et ceux situés de l'autre
côté de la rivière de la creuse qui est
vraiment à quelques kilomètres du grand
pressigny
[Musique]
valériane nous voici au pied du donjon
un donjon ou plutôt ce qu'il en reste
même si quand même une partie importante
le donjon était le coeur du château au
moyen-âge il a été érigé au 12e siècle
et rapidement il a été protégé par une
chemise qui est un rempart qui à coller
au plus près du donjon et qui étaient là
pour assurer la défense ultime bain du
donjon en cas d'attaqué merci beaucoup
voilà merci de nous avoir proposé cette
visite extérieure de ce site majestueux
on va maintenant se rendre à l'intérieur
du musée de la préhistoire avec notre
nouvel invité
[Musique]
nous nous retrouvons ici dans la cave du
château au sein du musée et dans ce
musée une collection majeur bonjour
frédéric une collection majeur de la dhr
connu dans le monde entier exact oui oui
et c'est sans les fameuses longue lame
du grand pressigny qui ont été produites
dans la région aux alentours de 2700 à
2004 avant jésus-christ dans des
tailleurs de silex spécialisé peut dire
professionnelle
dans la région aux alentours de 10 km
autour du musée actuel et on a trouvé
partout en europe jusqu'à oui oui c'est
l'âme là il se retrouve 15 900 km de
distance par rapport à un grand préciser
leurs zones de production c'est qui
prouve que c'était des c'était des
objets particuliers peut-être de luxe
qui qui était en fait reconnu comme tel
à travers une grosse partie de l'europe
au néolithique c'est à dire à l'époque
des premiers habitudes alors de luxe
mais ça sert également quelque chose à
quoi ça pouvait servir de faucille pour
moissonner le blé qu'il utilisait à
l'époque ça pouvait servir de couteau
mais certains sont très bien travaillé
c'est ce qu'on appelle des poignard en
silex du grand prix et que ça prouve que
c'était des objets de valeur ajoutée un
petit peu comme une belle montre de luxe
si vous voulez qui était réservé une
partie de la population de l'époque
[Musique]
nous sommes dans une salle qui
reconstitue un campement préhistorique
il ya vingt mille ans c'est l'époque de
la dernière grande ère glaciaire durant
laquelle les hommes de cro magnon
vivaient de la chasse était nomade
chasse cueillette pêche était nomade là
on a deux exemples de ces hommes de cro
magnon qui sont en fait des homo sapiens
comme vous et moi il ya 20 millions il
ya bien sûr la présence du sluc était
plus couverts ce qui a permis de
coloniser des secteurs très au nord et
froid c'est l'utilisation du feu mais le
feu est utilisé depuis au moins un
million d'années par les humains et là
on est à vingt mille ans donc il le
maîtrise très bien
[Musique]
merci beaucoup frédéric venez découvrir
la ville du grand pressigny son château
son musée de la préhistoire c'est à 58 2
tours au sud de la campagne tourangelle